sziasztok a következő vendégem todor
botond aki hangszerjavító és zenész is
egyben bevallom hogy ez a téma számomra
egy
nagyon érdekes téma volt ugyanis én nem
rendelkezek zenei háttérrel utána
kellett nézzek a hétvégémet azzal
töltöttem hogy megtanultam a különböző
fafúvós és részfúvós hangszereknek a
csinját binját ennek ellenére egy nagyon
izgalmas beszélgetésben volt részünk
ugyanis rengeteg dolgot tanultam
botontól aki a régiónk egyedüli fúvós
hangszerjvítója
tartsatok velünk a következő epizódban
és hogyha még nem tetted meg akkor
kérlek iratkozzatok fel a csatornánkra
adjatok egy lájkot valamint hagyjatok
egy kommentet ezzel is tudjátok segíteni
a csatornánk bővülését
üdvözlök minden kedves nézőt a mai
vendégem tódor botond lesz
hangszerjavító
és nagyon izgalmas kérdésekkel készültem
az az igazság hogy amikor megtudtam hogy
az egyik kedves ismerősöm ajánlotta am
úgy botondot és amikor megtudtam hogy
egy hangszerjavítóval fogok tudni leülni
beszélgetni akkor kezdtem így a a
kérdéseket listázni és alig tudtam
leállítani magam annyi kérdés jött fel
bennem nekem mint informatikus meg ebben
a pörgős világban élni ahol a dolgokat
nem annyira javítják meg hanem inkább
lecserélik vagy kidobják ez egy ez egy
nagyon izgalmas téma és vágjunk is bele
szerintem az első kérdés az hogy
hogyhogy hangszerjavítással kezdtél
foglalkozni egy kicsit mesélnél a a
hátteredről miket
tanultál hogy lesz valakiből
hangszerjavító
20008-tól a csízeredai nagyisvá
művészeti szakközépiskolába iratkoztam
be beiratott anyukám falusi gyerekként
és ott kezdtem el tanulni zenét
intenzíven ugye a művészeti iskolában
ott elég intenzíven veszik a zenét két
évig
csellóztam aztán a fúvós hangszerek
világa beszippantott akkor alakult a
csikzent simani fúvós zenekar 2008-ban
és
akkor elkezdtem trombitázni apukám
mondta hogy mikor mész fiam mon mondjad
hogy neked trombitát adjanak valamiért
édesapád is játszik hangszerek sajnos
nem apukám nem de visszamenőleg
nagytatám és déd nagytatám is és elvileg
nagyon sok felmenőm apukám felő fúvós
hangszereken játszott a régi öregektől
hallottam ilyen olyan sztorikat meg
legendákat apukámnak sajnos nem volt
erre lehetősége és elkezdtem bitázni
aztán rájöttem hamar hogy a vonós
hangszerek a cselló az valahogy nem az
én világom és akkor trombitáztam
igazából egészen az érettségig tehát
abból a trombitából érettségiztem a
művészetti iskolában időközben 2011-ben
elmentünk egy farsangtemetésre a helyi
hagyományőrző csoporttal a
csikszentsimoniakkal és hogyhogy nem
belefújtam egy szaxofonba
és apukám meglátta és azt mondta fiam ha
megtanul szaxofonozni én veszek neked
egy szaxofont na hát nem kellett kétszer
mondani mondtam jól van apu és meg is
vette a hangszert és elkezdtem
párhuzamosan a trombitát a
szaxofonnal tanulni aztán időközben
kimaradt a trombita és maradt a szaxofon
hogy hogy kerültem igazából a
hangszerjavítással kapcsolatban érdekes
de hogy ezt lehet tanulni ezt a ezt a
hangszerjavítást persze tehát van erre
egy külön képzés vagy vagy hogy képzelj
igen van ez úgy indult az egész
hogy
cikzentsimonban elég magas színvonalú
művésztáborok és zenetáborok voltak
minden nyáron és a 11 osztály és a 12
osztály közti vakációban jöttek
magyarországról nagyon
híres tanárok és felröppent ott a hír az
egyik kürtanár valami mondatot elejt
hogy de kár hogy ő nem végezte el a
hangszerészakot budapesten és akkor így
szegetütött a fejemen hogy hoppá létezik
ilyen hogy hangszerészképzés igen és
akkor utána jártam budapesten a liszt
ferencene művészeti egyetem keretén
belül működik a a hangszerészképzés
egy ilyen érettségi utáni képzés
budapesten ez hány éves k plusz
tehát három éves
de volt egy ilyen érdekes váltás hogy
két évben indítanak évfolyamot és egy
évben nem és amikor leérettségiztem pont
azt az évet kaptam el amikor amikor nem
indítottak évfolyamot a hangszerész
iskolában indíot azt tudni kell a a
hangszerészoktatásról hogy a
alapfeltétele az ahhoz hogy felvegyenek
az iskolába hogy egy gyakorlóműhelyt
találj magadnak budapesten belül ahová
téged felvesz a mester mint mint
gyakornok és
mint tanonc újonc tanuló idézőjelben úgy
hívtak minket tanulók és napi 8-9 órában
teljes munkaidőben gyakorlatilag
megmutatja hogy hogy kell fogni azt a
csavarhúzót hogy kell kiti képzés
mellett még gyakorltil k igen egy
hónapban két nap elméleti képzésünk volt
akkor tanultunk akusztikát szakrajzot
plusz minden más hangszert elméletbe
anyagismeret szakrajz azt már mondtam és
plusz minden héten volt egy szakmai
angol ühüm szakmai angol megtanultunk
emailt írni hogy mondják a
a vonalzónak hogy mondják a vésőnek hogy
mondják a rejbezninek hogy mondják a ez
ezt miért tartják ennyire fontosnak hogy
az angol a szakmai angol az menjen hát
vag szakmai német ugye vagy a szakmai
német hát azért hogyha kikerülsz a
szakmába akkor legalább tudj egy emailt
megfogalmazni rendelést
magadnak a rendelés é és a a kliensi kör
is akár lehet külföldi persze de például
ez neked amúgy egy tehát külföldről
vannak megrendeléseid igen svácból és
németországból is hoztak már hangszert
és akkor még egy gyors kérdés budapesten
hány ilyen műhely van ahol lehet
praktizálni hát attól függ hogy most
fúvós hangszerekről beszélgetün
beszéljünk fúvós hangszer kettő oszlik
itt is a témakör vannak a részfúvós
műhelyek és vannak a fafúvós műhelyek
nekem olyan szerencsém volt hogy olyan
műhelyben nyertem felvételt ahol 16 éve
nem fogadtak tanulót de valamiért
megtetszett nekik a a karakterem a kezem
és sz fiú eljöt a nagy mag h mondjuk
nagyon bizonyítani akartam tény é való
és azt akartam ebből kihozni hogy abba a
műhelybe részfúvósokat és fafúvósokat is
javítottak és abba az egy üres évbe
kimentem és részfúvós javításokat
tanultam hogy amikor elindul az évfolyam
a következő évbe elindult akkor fafúvós
szakirányba tudjak elmozdulni
szerintem sokkal komplexebb a fafúvós
hangszerek javítása mint mint a
részfúvósoké igen de akkor mind a kettőt
tanultad valójában nem igen tehát hogy
és és most a műhelyedben mind a kettőt
is javítasz v igen igen inkább fafúvós
hangszereket de részfúvósok is akadnak
szép számmal hm tehát akkor ez a a két
plusz egy év akkor eltelt budapesten
utána mi történt veled hát utána rögtön
2018-ban hazajöttem cssensimonba és
elkezdtem a kis műhelykémet fel hát
akkor ez így volt ez így a cél célként
ezt ed ki magadnak hogy miután elvégzed
akkor utána természetesen én úgy
indultam neki ennek a szakmának hogy
utána hazajövök és mivel elég hiány
szakma itthon ezt fogom csinálni itthon
szeté hány éű hely van itt a
környékünken egy sincs egy sincs akkor
akkor kicsit tágítj erdélyben hány ilen
van hát vannak
igazából olyan hangszeresek akik neki
fognak otthon javítgatni ezt azt de
professzionális fúvós hangszerműhely
vós hangszerész műhely igazából
országszinten nincsen tehát akkor ha jól
értem ha valaki egy zenész megszeretné
javíttatni a hangszerét akkor egyedül te
vagy itt monopolhelyzetbe nem mondanám
azt h monopol helyzetbe vannak akik
javítanak részfúós hangszereket de csak
így maszekba otthon délutánonként vannak
akik csak szaxofont meg clarinéot
javítanak de amikor bele kell menni a
mélyebb dolgokba egy jobó egy fúvóolajy
fagot ott azért senki nem meri a kezét
rá én mondjuk meg is értem egy ilyen
magas és nagy értékű hangszerhez nem
lehet csak úgy kókányul hozzányúlni van
hogy megpróbálják de általában álam köt
ki igen be kell valljam hogy a hétvégén
én is azzal foglalkoztam az az ismerősöm
aki aki ajánlott téged elküldött egy
ilyen prezentációt így a
hangszercsaládokról így gyerekeimmel
végignéztük a videókat hogy hogy hangzik
egy egy fúvala hogy hangzik egy fagott
és ésn most tanultam meg ezeket
nagyjából hogy hogy milyen típusú
hangszerek vannak és elképesztő
elképesztő milyen bonyolultak milyen
milyen összetettek
talán azzal is kezdhetnénk hogy a a
hallgatók számára el tudnád röviden
magyarázni hogy a fafúvós és a részfúvós
hangszerek miben különböznek honnan
kapták a nevüket hát ugye azt hinnié az
ember amelyik fából van az fafúvós
amelyik részből van az részfúvós b
vallom én is azt hittem nem így van a
hangszereket a megszólaltatásmódjuk
szerint osztályozzuk tehát vannak
részfúvósok és fafúvósok a szaxofon is
részből van de mégis fafúvósnak minősül
miért a részfúvós hangszereket prűzelős
technikával szólaltatjuk meg ugye a kis
fúvóa ott van és berezeg a szá ilyen kis
prűzölős mozdulatokkal az összes
részfúvós hangszert így szólaltatjuk meg
a fafúvósokat pedig ajaksíppal és
nyelvsíppal
bocsánat nád násippal
ugye a az a az alapvető különbség a
részfúvós és a fafúvós hangszerek
megszólaltatás módja között hogy amíg a
a rezgést a részfúvósoknál a száj végzi
el addig a a fafúvósoknál ezt elvégzi a
nád tehát teljesen más a megszólaltatás
módja aztán ez ezeken belül is
osztályozhatjuk szimplanádas
hangszerekre meg duplanádas hangszerekre
duplanádas hangszerek a zoboa angol kürt
fagott kontrafagott ugye ez már a
hangszercsaládok és és vannak a
simplanádas hangszeret mind a clarinate
mint a szaxofon tárú mit kz a duplanád
hát úgy kell elképzelni hogy van a
normál clarinét fúvóka bocsánat és egy
bambusznád nyelv hozzá van szorítva itt
van egy pici rés és ahogy az ember
befújja a levegőt az a elkezd rezegni az
a nád és így szólal meg a dupla
nádasoknál kettő darab nád van
összefordítva ühüm ühüm és
ahogy befújod a levegőt a két nád rezeg
gyakorlatilag és a akkor ez egy
cserélhető alkatrész maga a fúókkal
gondolom hogy azt gyakran cserélik é a
inkább a nádat inkább a nádat mag nádat
az elfáradt kigyengül a sok rezgéstől és
ki kell cserélni gyakorlatilag mennyi
időnként kell cserélni hát ez attól függ
van aki én például minden lagzi után
kicserélek a nádat annyira kigyengül
mondjuk mikor egy ilyen 13 órás túrát
lefújsz vele akkor hát
igazából ez a nehéz a fafúvós
hangszereknél hogy ez a folyamatos ná
probléma felteszel-e nádat nem szól
felteszel-e másikat az szól ésí
folyamatos például a a zoboisták meg a
fagottosok maguknak faragják a nádat
otthon
ühüm elég kényes dolog
igen azt el tudom képzelni hogy tehát
azt már tisztáztuk hogy attól hogy
fafúvós vagy rézfúvós egy hangszer az
nem azt jelenti hogy milyen anyagból
készül így van de úgy érdekelne hogy
milyen anyagokkal dolgozol tehát
hogy milyen nyersanyagokat kell te
beszerez külföldről ahogy mondtad
gondolom hogy fákat meg fémeket külön
meg mindenféle fákat meg fémeket men
fákkal dolg ragasztók hát ha azt vesszük
hogy a fafúvós hangszerek milyen fából
készülnek ugye a legelterjedbb például a
clariné vagy a tárogató esetében az az
ében fa grenadil kocoboló tehát
mindenképpen af afrikai keményfa igen
így van így van így van é ébenfát tehát
hogy lehet nyilván lehet vásárolni
megkapni de az ez y nagyon drága fa
fajta lehet nem hát az is
fekete aranynak is szokták becézni régen
még hozzá lehetett jutni olyan neves
gyárak mint a stovaszer például aki a az
első világháború előtt meg az 1800-as
évek végén nagyon híres és nagyon jó
minőségű hangszereket gyártott ők
megvették azelőtt 20 évvel 30 évvel a
fát afrikából brazíliából attól függ
ahonnan be tudták szerezni nagy
mennyiségben és akkor gyakorlatilag mint
hangszerf azt úgy tárolták hogy
száradjon akkor egyszer átfúrták a a
belső furatot megint pihentették az
anyagot tehát volt egyfajta úgy kell úgy
kell elképzelni mint mint régen az
asztalosok hogy nem minden fából készült
akármi megvolt melyikből lesz gerenda
melyikből lesz ajtó melyikből lesz
konyhabútor így van a fáknál is a
hangszerfáknál azt tudni kell hogy
nagyon meg vannak szigorodva a szabályok
most már világszinten nem lehet csak úgy
kivágni fát a jó hangszerfák meg
elfogytak kollégám szokta mondani hogy
igazából a jó hangszereket már
legyártották
igen ez a ez a fekete tehát ében fának
szoktuk de ez egy gyűjtőnév igazából az
ébenf grenadi kocobó az összes egzotikus
fa ide tartozik e ezek mennyi idő alatt
nőnek meg tehát hogyha most elültetnék
egy ében fa csemetét akkor mi menny idő
m lát több 100 több 100 több 100 év igen
hát úgy kell elképzelni ugye az ében fát
nem tudom láttál-e hogy csak
megfaraga egy ilyen hatalmas nagy vaskos
fa a külsáe ugyanúgy barna faszín és a
és a bel je a magja fekete
igen és nagyon nagyon sűrű gondolom huk
hogy hogy nem uszik a vizen például igen
akkor utána milyen fákat használnak még
a ugye a fagott esetében jávor havos
jávor abból készül a juhar jáávor attól
függ a fáknál parafa ugye rengeteget
használunk parafát a az ütközéseknél meg
a
hangszerzetoldásoknál akkor ugye fémeket
használunk a részfúvósoknál ugye benne
van a nevében hogy sárgarész de
használunk alpakát is az alpaka
ugyanazokkal a tulajdonságokkal
rendelkezik mint a sárgarész csak épp
szürke a színe abból készül például a
fúvola vagy a általában a billentyűk
bármilyen fafúvós hangszerre alpakából
készülnek gold messing ugye az a vörös
rész és a sárga rész közti átmenet
használunk
ezüstöt fémeket vörös réz
igazábólzisot mire használjátok például
forrasztásra forrasztásnál kétféle
forrasztást különböztetünk meg a
lágyforrasztás meg a keményforrasztás a
most nagyon belementünk a sűrűjébe a
lágyforrasztásnak az a lényege hogy
oltható például a szaxofon különböző
részei vagy a trombita különböző részei
cínnel vannak összeforrasztva hogyha
esetleg sérül akkor le lehet forrasztani
ki lehet igazítani újra lehet
forrasztani szépen meg lehet csinálni
tehát szétszedhető bontható az a
keményforrasztás által ezüstel szokták
rézel is de inkább ezüstel forasztunk az
nagyon magas hőfokon gyakorlatilag már
vörös az anyag és akkor forasztjuk meg
ezüstsel az az nem oltható kötés olyan
alkatrészeknél használjuk azt ahol
nagyon-nagyon kell tartsa egyik a
másikat és az nem olató igen hát az
következő kérdésem az az
hogy sok kérdésem van az anyagokkal
kapcsolatban az első térjünk vissza az
ébenhez hogy azt azt lehet valamivel
pótolni tehát vannak például el tudom
képzelni hogy műanyaggal vagy valamilyen
más típusú anyaggal ami modern anyag és
nem nem kell 200 évig várni hogy
kifelejtettem például az elefántcsontot
régen készültek elefántcsontból is ugye
a zongorabillentyűk is de készültek
például fúvolla fejek elefántcsontból de
mivel be van tiltva az
elefántcsontból a de ez inkább az
egzotikuma miatt egy egy olyan valami
vagy pedig tt úgy képzeld el hogy
ezelőtt 100 évvel meg 200 évvel nem volt
műanyag és az kellett valamilyen nagyon
kemény anyagal kemény anyaggal ami ami
tűri a nedvességet kellett
helyettesíteni és erre akkor tökéletes
anyag volt például az elefántcsont
a még egyszer a kérdést azérben igen
tehát hogy pont ezt akartam kérdezni
hogy most egy a műanyag elterjedésével a
modern világban nem lehet ezeket az
anyagokat pótolni például az ébenfát de
dehogy nem pótolják is már nagyon-nagyon
rég hogy műanyagból is készülnek
hangszerek de nem olyan a hangjuk min
nem olyan a hang ez lett volna a
következő kérdésem hogy professzionális
hangszerek kzülnek ébenfából és a tanuló
hangszerek az műanyag tehát egy egy egy
képzett fül meg tudja különböztetni a
műanyagot és az
ébenfát nem tudnám ezt így kijelenteni
inkább a zenész érzi a hangképzésnél
amikor megszületik az a hang hogy hogy
hogy válaszol a hangszer hogy rezonál
milyen szép kristálytiszta hangja van
inkább a zenész érzi ezt ühüm tehát
akkor akkor emiatt a hangszerek árai
mégis a professzionális szinten azért
mégis nagyon magasak
igen és az a legnagyobb probléma
igazából hogy méregdrága hangszerek
professzionális szinten úgy kell
elképzelni egy pár karinét most már
10000 euró is lehet egy a és egy b tehát
két hangszerről beszélgetünk és nem
olyanok a fák mint régen rebednek
száradnak mozognak mert ugye nincsenek
szárítva évtizedekig hanem cnc-be
berakják az megcsinálja és és nem olyan
a végeredmény és akkor ilyen szempontból
egy egy hangszer kiöregedhet mert még
most is lehet hallani ott van egy
például a strádivári hegedükről lehet
hallani több 100á évesek és nagyon
nagyon nagyon drágák tehát ilyen
szempontból vannak több 100 éves fúvós
hangszerek amik még mindig nagyon-nagyon
jól szólnak és az idők során a
technológia fejlődésével sem tudtak jobb
hangszert készíteni azt szoktam mondani
hogy a az a különbség a vonós hangszerek
meg a fúvós hangszerek között hogy ugye
hegedűből ugye vonós hangszerből brácsa
celló nagybőgő minél régebbi annál
értékesebb annál többet rezonál a fa
annál
annál jobban ki van száradva tehát
jobban válaszol több az értéke a
hangszerernek fúvós hangszernél igazából
minél újabb annál jobb ühüm mert
igazából itt itt
gyakorlatilag a a fa hangszertest
gyakorlatilag ha jó fája van akkor az az
elvileg nagyon sokáig jó lehet itt
mindig a mechanizmussal van baj ugye a
fémalkkatrészek azok kikopnak kikopnak
elkopnak lehet egy bizonyos szintig
javítani de bizonyos szint után már
gyakorlatilag kellene egy teljesen új
fémmechanika és akkor az már
megint nem nem rentábilis igazából igen
hát ez lett volna a következő kérdésem
hogy mi alapján tudod eldönteni hogy
most már nyilván a kliens döntie hogy
hogy még hajlandó-e befektetni annyi
pénzt de emlékszem hogy édesapám amikor
még a kommunizmus lejárt az egyik
terve az volt hogy indít egy olyan
javító céget ahol hajszárító mindenféle
elektronikai cikkeket javítanak és az
elején tényleg hoztak hozzá
hajszárítókat meg mindenféle ilyen
olcsóbb elektronikai cikkeket de elég
hamar kiderült hogy ezér nem nem lesz
egy jövedelmező vállalkozás úgyhogy be
is kellett zárja ezt a a frissen
indulóboltot de a hangszer az mégsem egy
hajszárító tehát az már hát nem nem és
és gyanítom hogy ilyen szempontból azért
nem kell te tarts attól hogy hogy 10 20
30 vagy 50 év múlva is akár a
hangszereket inkább az egyik billentyűje
meg nem tudom hogy mit mi történhet vele
tegyük fel meglazul akkor akkor inkább
eldobják a hangszert mintogy megjavítsák
hát az az igazság itt két dolgot kell
megkülönböztetni a hangszer milyen
értéket képvisel hogyha egy például
legendás hangszer fafúósok esetében a
zelmer mark 6-os
szaxofon annál jobbat még nem gyártottak
le a világon azt az 50-es60-as évekbení
a a
kezdő tapasztalatlan énemnek magyarázd
el hogy ez mitől értékes meg mitől
különleges ez a zelmer hát ugye a zelmer
az egy francia márka igen és több mint
100 éve hogy fafúvós hangszereket
gyártanak gyártottak részfúvósokat is
egy kevés ideig de főleg szaxofonra meg
clarinéra vannak ráállva gyakorlatilag a
a világ top hangszergyártói benne van a
zelmer mindenki zelmer szaxofonon akar
játszani és
mennyibe kerül egy zelmer szaxofon ott
is vannak kategóriák tudod de most mondj
egy nagy árat nekem hogy h ken hát ilyen
14000€ó például
egy egy középkategóriás h nem tehát nem
a elmerből úgy tudom hogy most 5000€óér
a legújabbat az elmer supremot meg lehet
venni vannak olyan régi legendás
modellek például a az 54-es vagy a mark
6-os mondom az az a világ valaha
gyártott legjobb szaxofonja tehát olyan
árakért mennek el ha lehet kapni
egyáltalán valahol valamiért a gyár ott
egy olyant alkotott amit azóta
se olyan anyaghasználat olyan arányok
olyan anyagvastagság és ezt nem tudja
lemásolni nem lehet ezt újra nem tudták
azóta se lemásolni kijött 1000er darab
típus és és nem a az elmer markatos az a
a szaxofon például a fagottok esetében a
heckel a hackel fagottokért meghallják a
fagottosok a hackelt és remegni kezdenek
annyira te valaha fogtál egy ilyen zemer
szaxofont a kezedbe persze hogy és és
játszottál is rajta persze és és tényleg
érződik rajta hogy ez ez ez most egy
különleges hangszer tehát hogy te mint
zenész amúgy még nem terjed nem nem
beszéltünk konkrétan a zenei zenészi
oldaladról de te mint zenész akkor érzed
azt hogy ez valami különleges
persze azt igazából amikor az ember már
egy kicsit
konyit a a zenéhez pár évet eltöltött
pár év fúj akkor érzi meg hogy igazából
mi a különbség egy professzionális
hangszer között meg egy kezdő hangszer
között mert a laikusnak ugyanúgy szól
mind a kettő de nem mindegy hogy nekem
hogy válaszol a hangszer milyen könnyű a
hangindítás lehet-e fentről le szépen
kötni váltani hogy segít-e a hangszer
vagy pedig visszatartó erő a hangszer
tehát hogy plusz munkát kell belefektess
ahhoz hogy megpróbáld ugyanazt a
hangzást elérni vagy pedig vagy pedig
szinte egy tánc el tudom képzelni egy í
saját identitása van ennek a a
hangszernek olyan nyomasznyi dolgokon
múlik igazából hogy hát azt kell
elképzelni hogy egy szimfonikus
zenekarbaan ott olyan kristály tisztán
kell fújni azt tudni kell a fúvós
hangszerek nagyon érzékenyek a
nedvességtartalomra nagyon érzékenyek a
hőmérsékletre persze fel felmennek egy
picit en hangot lemennek járkálnak de
gondom a vonósak is ilyen szempontból
érzékenyek nem vagy annyira nem a nem
érzékenyek igen de egy professzionális
hegedűs például érzi hogy elment és egy
picit fenné nyúl egy picit fenné fogja
fafúós hangszerek esetben fafúós
hangszerek esetébe ki van fúrva az adott
hangjuk azt lefogtad lehet intonálni egy
picit szájból fj le de
úgyhogy igen és akkor egy ilyen szaxofon
az az kevésbé érzékeny egy enzelmer
szaxofon
igen ott inkább a a a hangszín meg a azt
szokták mondani a vaskossága a hangnak
van egy magia a hangnak mikor ezt nem
tudom elmagyarázni ezt mikor belefújsz
akkor
érzed hát pedig még lehet hogy
nyomorgatni foglak ezzel a kérdésen mert
pont ez az a a laikusok számára nagyon
nehezen megközelíthető érzés mert ahogy
mondtad az aki tapasztalt és belefúj na
most két dolog ami miatt nem fogok én
soha belefújni eg ken belefújat és és
nem fogom érezni azt de talán ha
beszélgetünk róla jobban megértem erre
még vissza fogunk térni most egy kicsit
arról kérdeznélek hogy egy hangszer
javítása az körülbelül mennyi idő most
hogy képzeljem el hogy most valaki hoz
egy hangszert mennyi időt szoktál
dolgozni most nyilván attól függ hogy
milyen baja van de hogy egy kicsit
beszélj erről nekünk hogy hát igazából
az a kérdés hogy nagy javítás teljes
generál teljes felújítás restaurálás
idézőjelbe vagy pedig egy kicsi apró
beavatkozás egy kis szerviz vagy
tisztítás be állítás igazából fél órától
lehet egy hónapig is volt olyan hogy egy
hónapig dolgoztál egy hangszeren volt de
hogy mellette semmilyen más hangszeren
hanem arra hát mellette csináltam mást
is de inkább azt ühüm vannak olyan nagy
komplex munkák egy felújításnál például
egy fagotnál újra lakkozni kiszedni az
összes oszlopot zéróról gyakorlatilag
fel kell építeni a hangszert újra és az
bizony eszi a munkaórákat és ben van az
biztos de hogy az benned van ez a
magabiztosság hogy most ott van ez a
fagot egy hónapot kell dolgozni rajta
biztos ennek a személynek aki aki ezt a
fagotot ideehozta ez sokat jelent ez a
hangszer benned van ez a magabiztosság
hogy szétszedem apró darabjaira és
összerakom és szólni fog hát persze ezt
úgy kell elképzelni mint a lépcsőfokot
hogy első lépcső fok második
harmadik kicsit monotonnak tűnhet ez a
munkafolyamat de ha minden egyes apró
dolog meg van csinálva be van állítva
meg van tisztítva helyre van rakva akkor
a végeredmény egy gyönyörű és jól szóló
hangszer lesz hm ez nem ilyen találomra
megy hogy most akkor keresem a baját
vagy vagy hozzápiszkálok ide és akkor
lássuk jobb lesz-e teeh egy hangszerész
kell tudja hogy ránéz a hangszerre
sokszor jönnek a zenészek és fújkáljak
nekem hallod ennél a hangnál én kezembe
veszem a ledcsíkot beleteszem a
hangszerbe és látom hogy mi a probléma
tehát nem kell n megfújam e miér ez a
lsék egy kicsit kibontod nekem hát azt
úgy kell elképzelni ugye a a fafúvós
hangszerek belseje az gyakorlatilag
légüres tér igen a egy légoszlop
gyakorlatilag sok pici hangjuk tehát
fentről megindul például a szxofon ilyen
pici pici hangjukak és akkor egyre
nagyobb hangjukak vannak egészen a
tölcsérig ezeket a
hanglyukakat bőrpárnák fedik be
általában és akkor hermetikusan kell
kell a kell takarjon az p így van amikor
találkozik a hangjuk akkor hermetikusan
tökéletesen zárja le hogy ugye minél
több billentyűt becsukunk annál mélyebb
lesz az adott hang és
a ledcsíkot azért szoktam belerakni a
hangszerbe e sima ledcsík igazából és
akkor látom hogy hol szürődik ki a fény
érted érted és ahol kiszűrődik a fény
ott nem takar a hangszer
ötletes szóval itt azt ez is lenne a
következő kérdésem hogy ahogy a
technológia fejlődik újabb és újabb
anyagok újabb és új
eszközök szerszámok jelennek meg ezek a
te szakmád is így akkor fejlődik nyilván
a ledcsík az már egy konkrét eszköz amit
használsz egy olcsó módszer hogy hogyan
hogyan vizsgáld meg hogy valahol
szűrődik-e k fény de például nem tudom a
3d-s nyomtatás megjelenik-e a
hangszerjavításnál vagy vagy más anyagok
amikre még senki nem gondolt meg
megjelenik általában az a tapasztalat
hogy ezek a z új szilikon például azt is
használjuk a ragasztáshoz vagy vagy
ilyen mindenféle szintetikus
anyagok kipróbálják de általában nem
tudja helyettesíteni a természetes
anyagot például most parafáról
beszélgetek azt is biztos te is láttad a
parafadugók helyett most már ilyen olyan
úgy néz ki mint a parafa de ilyen szívű
igen ilyen szivacsos a hangszer
hangszerés szakmába is ezt próbálták
behozni de egyszerűen nem jó de mondjuk
a parafa az nem egy olyan drága fa hogy
érdemes legyen az vagy igen az a az hát
a ugye a parafa az a para tölgyinek gak
gyakorlatilag az egy fajta tölgy annak a
kérge és ezt lehántják gyakorlatilag és
attól függ hogy első osztály
másodosztály éles pengékkel felvágják
felszeletelik és olyan méretűre olyan
vastagságúra készítik el vannak erre
szakosod a cégek amienre nekünk
szükségünk van de ez a kivágott és jó
minőségű parafa egy az hogy egyre
kevesebb van és a másik az hogy nagyon
drága h na errő nem mond és akkor a para
tölgynek a kérge visszanő és akkor
megint le le leet majd hantani
üm visszatérve a kérdésedhez
hogy tehát visszatérve a kérdésedhez
hogy változik-e a szakma az évtizedek
alatt azt kell mondjam hogy nem sokat
hm egy nagyon érdekes helyzetben vagy én
én mint informatikus most elmondom az én
világkétemet ahogyan változik és és és
mindjárt meglátod hogy mennyire
kontrasztos az én szakmám gyakorlatilag
nem hogy évről évre hónapról hónapra
változik és pláne miután ez a
mesterséges intelligencia hullám bejött
mint programozó gyakorlatilag hétről
hétre kell figyelni most kijött a claude
3.7-es nézzük meg a grock hom hogyan
működik szóval ezek olyan dolgok hogy
kijön hétfőn és csütörtökre már
nagyjából kell tudni vele dolgozni ahhoz
hogy hogy hogy hogy egy hogy
versenyképesek maradjunk és az aki nem
tanul azok lassan a hetek a hónapok
ahogy telnek először érződik így
akkumulálódik úgymond a az a lemaradás
és ezen sokat gondolkoztam hogy például
egy kovácsszakma a középkorban
generációkon keresztül nem fejlődött
látványosan apró mikró dolgok fejlődtek
de hogy ez ez egy ez egy a világunk
megváltozott ellentétben bizonyos
szempontból amit mondtál hogy a te
szakmád ilyen rejtélyes módon végülis
nem változik olyan jelentősen szóval
hogy ez ez
hogy látod hogy a jövőben is
valószínűleg konzerválódni fog vagy
pedig figyelned kell azért a vannak
szakmai fórumok például amiken te is
részt
hát
kevés az az igazság hogy ez a szakma is
úgy kihaló félben van ugye nyugoton
úgy képzeld el hogy például nyugati
országokban nincs hangszerjavító mert
nincs ennek hagyománya például
magyarországon azért van hagyománya
hangszer készítésnek meg javításnak mert
például a kommunizmus mondom nem
lehetett kibejárkálni az országba és a
ami ami hangszer bent volt azt meg
kellett javítani ezért
mesterem m többször beszéltünk erről
hogy a igazából a magyarországi
hangszerjavítás meg a a képzés az elég
magas szintű
világszintű de de azt nem értem hogy
akkor mit csinálnak nyugodton azokkal a
hangszerekkel am amik el van ott is
egy-két szakember aki javít de általában
min az én esetemben is az van hogy túl
vagyunk le vagyunk terhelve túl vagyunk
terhelve egyszerűen annyi a megjavítandó
hangszer hogy
elég elég nagy elég nagy határidőkkel
dolgozun em az
árról van olyan hangszer is a műhelyben
amit már három éve kifizettek és még
mindig nem tudtam hozzányúlni ez ez így
van hogy a keresletkínálat törvénye
szabja majd meg az árakat úgyhogy
tényleg hogyha ennyire szűk meesgyén
tehát te csak te vagy elérhető akkor
tényleg az áraidon érdemes akkor növelni
viszont a de attó még kérdéses hogy most
egyébkén németországban a fagott
elromlik valakinek akkor akkor mit
csinál németországban még mindig sokkal
drágább a javítás
sokkal drágább mint egyúj hangszer nem
sokkal drágább mint itthon de akkor mit
csinál a német az a hangszerével amelyik
megond elviszi hangszerészhez csak
négyszer annyit fizet például mint
magyarországon jó tehát akkor valójában
a hangszerész szakma ott is ugyanúgy ott
ott megvan és valamilyen szempontból
kéne virágozzon ahogy egyre több
kultúrát fogyasszunk egyre egyre több
zenész van nem érzem azt hogy egyre több
kultúrát
fogyasztunk nem érzem azt sőt
egyre
kevesebb klasszikus zenét hallgatunk
vagy minőségi könnyű zenét vagy népzenét
azt látom hogy amióta a youtube
megjelent meg meg az internet mindenki
azt hallgat amit akar már az élőzenének
a becsülete úgymond elveszett jó ez ez
egy eléggé utóisztikus de de tényleg
ebbe az irányba tartunk nem tudják az
emberek értékelni azt hiszik hogy hogy
hogy te zenegép vagy hogy neked minden
mindent tudni kell tudnék erről mesélni
igazából hogy hétvégéről hétvégére
mikkel találkozok van egy közép réteg
egy értelmiségi réteg aki eljár
színházba eljár
koncertekre de ahhoz képest hogy
régen hogy mentek a zenekarok hát
például nézzünk meg itt is romániában a
kommunizmus idején jó most nem komoly
zenéről beszélgettünk de igazából minden
gyárnak minden vállalatnak volt énekkara
volt zenekara összeálltak az amatőrök
magyarországon
ugyanígy most
nincs most nincs
egy kicsit mesélj erről a mondtad hogy a
hétvégéről hétvégére én én tudom hogy te
lagakzikban is szoktál zenélni de ez ez
mit jelent gyakorlatban hány hétvégét
foglalt és kicsit mesélj erről a
világról milyen ez a há hát
van egy
vigabend névre hallgató
zenekarunk 201 óta vagyok tagja négy
személyből áll két
billentyűs egy hegedű meg egy szaxi
felváltva énekelünk mindenki a saját kis
stílusát hát miről szól arról szól hogy
mikor lejár a böjt húsvét után
nekifogunk a szezonnak és november yig
halottak napjáig minden hétvégén toljuk
vagy egy lakzi vagy egymás után két
lakzi péntek
szombat minden hétvégét foglalt akkor
igen ezt a családot hogy
bírja meg kérdezni a feleségemet hát
megkérjük a kedves feleségemet egy
kommentet majd írjon a videól nem
egyszerű azt kell mondanom
de nehéz ezt az egyensúlyt megtalálni
hogy hét közben a műhelybe is haladjak
gyakorlatilag hétvég azért éjszakázni
nyomni és plusz még a családra is az
biztos idő jusson és akkor még nem
beszéltünk arról hogy otthon a a ház
körül a tennivalók satöbbi satöbbi na
erre mondják
hogy egy fenékkel két lovat nem lehet
megülni hát még hármat mi lesz a jövője
szerinted ennek a
lagxzis oldaladnak meddig fogod tudni
ezt még így csinálni meddig akarod
csinálni hát egyelőre nagyon-nagyon
szeretem és
gyakorlatilag 13 éve már hogy az
éjszakákban mozgok és most látom azt
hogy beérett a gyümölcse ühüm tehát
tehát most kezd most van egy
felszállópályán ez a igen tehát
gyakorlatilag most aratom rá azokat a
babérokat amit amit amit gyakorolt am
éveken keresztül elég sikeres a
zenekar elég elég jól keresünk eléggé be
van futva a a banda úgymond és a
kollégákkal is nagyon jó a viszony ez
azért nagyon-nagyon fontos mert amikor
elveszed a családodtól a az értékes időt
a hétvégét azt nem mindegy hogy milyen
kollégákkal töltöd ugye röhögünk végig
toljuk az egész hétvégét jól telik
és mi volt a kérdés
igen tehát az az érd hogy a két életed a
két vállalkozásod között hogy látod a
dinamikát hogy merre halad a a
lakzizenés és akkor most gyakorlatilag
inkább azt kérdezném meg hogy merre
halad a hangszerjavítás hogy látod hogy
a azzal mi lesz a következő ö évben a
mesterem figyelmeztetett rá hogy előbb
utóbb választani
kell szerintem majd a a zenélés fog egy
kicsit háttérbe
szorulni
mert kiöregedek úgymond idézőjelbe
jönnek a fiatalok megát hát én sem úgy
bírom már az éjszakázásokat mint régebb
azért az idegrendszernek enni ad
rendesen ez a sok
éjszakázás meg lehet benned is lejár
tehát az a lelkesedés meg az az öröm ami
most úgy amit látok rajtad lehet hogy
majd egy idő után alábbhagy és azt
mondod hogy most már elég de hát ez
természetes ami természetes a csúcson
kell abbahagyni azt szokták mondani
hangszerjavítás meg azt igazából
nyugdíjas koron még meg ha lesz nyugdíj
ha lesz nyugdíj ha lesz nyugdíj azt amíg
a jóisten erőt ad a két kezemet fel
tudom emelni addig azt tudom c csinálni
hm otth van a kis műhelykében a melegbe
zenét hallgatok viszem a kávét
kollégával beszélgetünk kopogtatjuk a
hangszereket állítgatjuk jó kis hangulat
az hát remélem amikor szent simonba
járok akkor meg tudlak látogatni ny váak
nagyon sok szeretet erre a hangulatra
van egy akkor egy munkatársad el tudod
képzelni hogy még még legyenek inasaid
úgymond hát az az igazság a műhely
mérete az
korlátoz ketten jól elvagyunk igazából
nem tehát hiába vállalnék
össze még több munkát és újoncokkal
dolgoztatnék az lehet hogy a sőt biztos
vagyok benne hogy a minőség rovására
menne így ketten tudunk konzultálni útba
tudom igazítani és látom gyakorlatilag
hogy mit adunk ki a kezünkből mindig
átnézem
tehát ez is egy bizalmi dolog ugye igen
kezdett tanítani neki az alaplépéseket
hál istennek tamással úgy hívják erdély
tamás a kollégámat három éve együtt
dolgozunk és elég jól kijövünk hála
istennek a szakmáját alázattal
tisztességgel és precízen végzi és mint
ember is szót értünk úgyhogy egyelőre
megtaláltam ez ez nagyon szép az a
tisztelet ahogy beszéltél a mesteredről
kicsit olyan tényleg mint egy
harcművészetbe vagy vagy egy most így a
a jedi mester jut eszembe hogy valójában
van egy hierarchia és van egy kell
legyen yz emberben egy alázat hogy a
szakmát azt az egy folyamat megtanulni
kapsz egy hagyatékot és azt a hagyatékot
alázatosan minél inkább megtanulod
megtanulod elsajátítani és majd tovább
adod és ez a folyamatosság ez ez ez ez
számomra ez ez nagyon szép szép gesztus
és ahogyan beszéltél a mesteredről ez
nagyon tetszett gyanítom a
munkatársadnak te vagy a mestere aki aki
tanítod ez a ez a mestered budapesti aki
három mesterrel dolgoztam együtt a
műhelyben kettő darab részfúós mester
andrik istván rész fúvósmester és balog
miklós részfúvósmester és andréka gábor
fafúvósmester ők hárman terelgettek
irányítgattak tanítottak és
ezennel is szeretném nekik megköszönni
és amíg élek hálás vagyok hogy
befogadtak az az igazság hogy ez egy ez
egy kaszt ez egy szűk közösség ez egy
szűk közösség igen és
hogy mondjam bizonyítani kell ahhoz hogy
nem tudom mi határozza meg hogy
egyátalán miért voltam nekik szimpatikus
de de elég szoros a viszony úgy képzeld
el hogy amikor elmentem próbamunkára
akkor mondtam ó nyugodtan tegezzenek és
közölte a mesterem hogy magázódni fogunk
egészen addig ameddig nem teszem le a a
hangszerészvzsgát képzeld el úgyhogy
magázodtunk
egy 60 éves ember magázott engem és tudd
meg hogy ez adott egy szépséget eg
fennköltséget a szakmának
én nagyon-nagyon szerettem ott köztük
lenni szakmai közegvet közü körül
igazából hiányzik egy picit szakö ez y
valódi beavatási szertartás valójában
mikor amikor a a vizsgádat letetted
abban a pillanatban megisszátok a pertut
gondolom vagy vagy nem tudom hogy
képzeljem el fogjuk rá és é tehát az egy
milyen megtiszteltetés amikor először
tegezitek
egymástá úgyhogy úgyhogy ez ez ez
tényleg egy és akkor akkor hogy
képzeljem el tehát hogyha vannak
nehezebb munkáid akkor felhívod a
mestered és megkérdezed hogy hogyan
lehetne ezt megcsinálni volt sokszor
hogy tanácsot kértem
igen nem fogja tudni webkamerán
keresztül megmutatni a mester hogy azt
hogy kell de el tudja magyarázni vagy
vagy egy információt kérdezek tőle vagy
ühüm b vagy vagy ha egy nehezebb eset
van akkor esetleg elküldöd neki hogy
vagy volt még nem volt olyan nagy-nagy
javításokat például ilyen a részfúvós
hangszerek lakkozása az egy hatalmas
meló
szét kell kapni az egész hangszert
szétforrasztani minden egyes
alkatrészét ugye hordpadásokat kiszedni
belőle kivosalni lecsiszolni lepolírozni
újra összeforrasztani az egész hangszert
megint lepolírozni és elküldeni
lakkozóműhelybe ahol lelakkozzák
ez eléggé nagy munka az az igazság itt
lakkozóműhely úgy kell elképzelni a
lakozóműhelyt mint egy autófestődét
gyakorlatilag csak légmentesen zárva van
zsírtalanít fürürdő van amibe bemártják
a hangszert gyakorlatilag te egy csomó
dolgozol előkészíted a hangszert és hogy
a lakkozás hogy fog sikerülni az nem
tőled függ az nem tőled függ igen és az
hogy
itt rengeteg munkaórát beleöjek egy
ilyen felújításba aztán hamar
bugyoláljon be a végén rongyba és
utazzak vele 800 km budapestikor
lelakozzák hangszert ez nem rentábilis
úgyhogy ilyen például résfós hangszerek
lakozását azt nem vállalom ők fel vannak
erre készülve ott vannak budapesten
tövén úgymond ott vannak és nekik ez
könnyebben megy ilyen szintű javításokat
nem vállalok részfuss hangszerek
lakkozását de egyebet de ez a lakkozás
ez lehetne egy potenciális kiegészítése
a mostani műhelyednek így a jövő
maximálisan igen igen ez gondolom ez itt
már a technológia megjelenik tehát
gondolom itt olcsóbban lehet jobb
minőségű munkát végezni mint azelőtt nyü
fel 30 vagy 50 ével hát az az igazság
hogy például lak m miért ilyen fényes c
a részfúós hangszerek adott a réz azt
magas fényűre felpolírozzák
átlátszólakkal lefújják és beteszik
kemencébe ráég lak így így marad fényes
a a a a részfúós hangszer és
az európai uniós szabványok miatt már
nem gyártnak olyan jó lakkokat mint
régen laklemaró például a kromofág a
híres kromofág magyarországon rátetted a
hangszerre és már már bugyogott fel a a
lakkozás most már olyan gyenge
vegyszerek vannak igazából hogy mert
ezek toxikus anyagok is egybe gondol hát
persze hogy toxikus anyagok ezért van
korlátozva meg szigorítva a szabványok
miatt és ugye már nem olyan a lakkozás
például egy ilyen méregdrága zelmer
szaxofonról beszélgetünk elkezdett
használni és a a a nedvességtől az
izzadságtól lekopik a lakk kiadtad a sok
pénzt érte és egy egy éven belül lemegy
róla lak és nincs amit csinálj na
visszatérve az elmerre a a neki merné
fogniy ez elmer neki is megjavítani hát
miért ne miért ne fognék hát nem tudom
mert mert mert így így laikusként nekem
én félnéket olyan mint a hájó nem ez
bocsánat ez nem nem olyan mint a
hájókovács tehát ennek megvannak a
lépései de hát én úgy érezném tehát ez a
különbség talán köztünk hogy hogy mivel
nagy a tét ezért biztos hog rezegne a a
légysz kételkednék a tudásomban vajon
tényleg eleget tudok hozzá elég ha
kételkedsz a tudásodba akkor ne
csináld magabiztosság és a szakmai
felkészültség nag nagyon fontos tehát
ahhoz hogy nyilván a mesterem se adott
nekem érek drága hangszereket a kezembe
és amikor hazakerültem budapestről és
elindítottam a műhelyt akkor nekem már
jöttek a drága hangszerek és nincs is
addig baj amíg egyedül vagyok és és
dolgozgatok rajta hanem mikor jönnek a
zenészek és akkor kábé így 10 cm-ől
nézik hogy te mit csinálsz méregetnek
akkor persze megremeg az embernek a keze
akkor szoktam is kérni hogy
igazából megértem a zenészeket is ilyen
az a meghosszabbított kezük igazából a
hangszer igen azzal keresük a kenyerüket
abba fújjáak bele bánatukat örömüket és
féltik de azt érzem néha néha túlzottan
is féltik a a hangszert deát ez most
igazából olyan mint hogy anya túlzottan
félti a gyerekét nem lehet eléggé
túlzottan félteni tudod
én egy kicsit gyakorlatiasabban látom a
hangszert a zenész pedig érzelmileg
kötődik hozzá én pedig nekem egy
ugyanolyan mechanika tarty
igen hát ez ez ez egy ilyen érdekes
dolog mert úgy ahogy mondtad össze van
nőve a zenész a hangszerével tehát egy
közös identitást alkotnak és amikor
odaadja akkor a felét odaadja a a zenész
saját magából na most miután te
felújítod lehet hogy azt mondja h hát ez
nem pont úgy szól mint a gondolhatom én
mint ahogy ahogy szólt előtte ilyenkor
mit tudz csinálni meg lehet hát igazából
mindig kell közölni a a zenésszel hogyha
ezek a a javításokat végzem el rajta az
így befolyásolhatja a végeredményt a
hangzást igazából itt a a visszatérve az
előző témára a bizalom nekem fel kellett
építenem a bizalmat a az ország elég sok
fúvós zenészével bizonyítanom kellett
azt szoktam mondani a legjobb reklám az
a jól elvégzett munka és mai napig
igyekszek eszerint eljárni hogy csak
olyan dolgokat adjak ki a kezemből amit
amit amit megéri volt olyan javításod
amire még most is emlékszel ami ami
különlegesen úgy ki van világik igen
vannak vannak vannak a gondolom a
legnehezebb javítások közé tartozik igen
igazából ezt
én én szolgálatként fogom fel egy picit
ezt a
hangszerjavítást a mesterem mondta hogy
annál jobb érzés nincs amikor délelőtt
nálam járt az oboista és este beülök az
operába és hallom hogy milyen szépen
szól
azobó ezzel én is így vagyok és tudd meg
hogy olyan hálások tudnak lenni a
zenészek az a gond a a fús hangszerrel
hogy a zenész a hangszernek a
hiányosságaihoz és a hibáihoz
alkalmazkodik idővel tehát érzi
folyamatosan romlik a hangszer de még
szájból odafúja még kicsit jobban
rányomja a párnákat és amikor már
tényleg nem szóal akkor jönnek el hozzám
és amikor újjászületik a hangszer
gyakorlatilag is belefújnak újra meg
kell szokja igen mert már nem kell
erőlködni tehát úgy ahogy az előbb is
mondtam hogy a hangszer az téged
segítsen kell üüm nem a nem tehát nem
hátráltató tényező kell legyen a
hangszer arról hogy egyáltalán a zenére
tudj figyelni és ne a hangszer hibáira
így a
a mondtad hogy hogy a mestereddel sokat
konzultálsz tényleg vannak ilyen
mesterfogások ilyen titkos tanok amiket
hogyha amiket csak bizonyos műhelyekben
csinálnak vagy ez egy ez egy olyan
általános tudás hogy mindenhol mindenki
ugyanazt csinálja azt mondta a mesterem
hogy kiminek a mestere annak a huncuttja
ez nagyon jó mondás és
ugyanez a mesterem mondta hogy a mi
szakmánk
megfelelő időben megfelelő helyre
megfelelő erővel mért
kalapácsütés ez így van ez így van és
vannak persze hogy vannak mesterfogások
és de olyan például amit tud tudod hogy
ezt most nem szívesen adod ki a kezedből
mert ezt te tudod te tanultad ezt a lép
ez egy titkos valami egy titkos mozdulat
nincs titok itt önzőség lenne ha nem
adnám át a a
tudást mesterem se volt önző átadta
annyi hogy én kellett volna többet
kérdezzek a gábor mesteremmel volt egy
volt egy ilyen hogy elég szótlan típus
volt ő mondta hogy kérdezzek ha valamit
nem tudok én is mai napig mondom
tamásnak kérdezé ha valamit nem tudsz ne
menj a saját fejed után és akkor persze
hogy amikor már bakiztam vagy valami
olyan csináltam akkor utánaá miért nem
szóltál miért nem kérdezted az ember
hajlamos arra hogy kicsit tönfejűen
próbálgatja a dolgokat de azért a mester
az mester
hm ezt el tud képzelni valaki úgy
javítson a hangszert hogy önmaga nem
játszik azon a hangszeren nem tud
játszani persze
egyértelmű a zongorahangolók és a
zongorakészítők szeme nem egy
lisztferenc és nem egy
shopen vagy például ott van nagy ákos
címbalomkészítő barátom mester mesterem
budapestről világ egyik legjobb
címbalomkészítője és nem egy síbalon
virtuus hüüm tehát külön külön szoktam
választani nagyon jó hogyha tudsz rajta
játszani az csak előny de nem
feltétele mert a a zene a hangszerem val
a zenélés egy dolog és maga a mechanika
az anyag az teljesen más dolog ezt
érdekes hogy így külön lehet választani
bár ugy ahogy mondtad a te esetedben
abszolút ez egy előny hogy hogy
maximálisan előny igen amúgy te hány
hangszeren ját lehet-e ilyet kérdezni
hogy hányféle hát az összest meg tudom
szólaltatni azt hogy hányon já igazából
s szaxofonozok meg tárogatózok ez a két
hangszer amit most már csinálok nem trom
vitázok évek óta de az egészet meg tudom
szólaltatni
ki tud ez azért mert egy adott családon
belül ugyanaz a fogás ugyanaz a ígygy
így van és ak akkor hány család van ami
ami amit meg tud szólaltatni hát most
így ami ami teljesen különböző amit
külön meg kellett tanulni hát igazából a
dupla nádasok voltak azok amik amikkel
egy kicsit meg kellett küzdenem de ott
sem a maga a mechanika meg az újrend
hanem hanem inkább a megszólaltatás
módja vogy a fúvolának például ezt
szépen ideteszed az ajkathhoz és
kristály tiszta hosszú hangot fújál a az
a különbség a zenész meg a hangszerész
között a zenész úgy fúja meg a hangszert
hogy megszülessen az a hang a
hangszerész pedig úgy fúja meg hogy
keresi a hibát
ez a különbség ezért van hogy belefújok
egy hangszerbe például a klarinéba vagy
a fúvolába és ott áll a fuvolista
mellettem és nézi hogy ez
mi kicsi finomságokon kell keresni a a
hibát és vannak erre ilyen digitális
eszközök is amivel lehet például egy
hangszínbe ker keresni a hibát vagy vagy
nem tudom ez ez mind csak fül alapján
tör hát fúvolára gyártottak ilyen ilyen
vákuum szerkezetet állítólag nem láttam
csak képeken hogy bedugod a végét
lenyomod a a a billentyűket és akkor
ahol ereszt digitálisan kijelzi de
igazából ez akkora hülyeség megvannak a
a kézi módszerek hogy megnézzed hogy hol
ereszt és a pikpak megkapod a problémát
tehátses
igen ilyen tettek rá a kísérletet hogy
ilyen modern dolgokat behozzanak de
igazából minden a régi meg kell csinálni
úy amúgy el tudnád-e képzelni hogy
tegyük fel 30 év múlva olyan forradalmi
új technológiákat használjanak a
hangszerjavításban amire most még nem is
gondolsz javításb nem tudom elképzelni a
gyártásb igen ilyen például a cnc ühüm
régen a mester kiesztergálta azt a fát
kézzel lehúzta belefúrta a hangjukat
mérte rajzok szerint most beprogramálják
a cnc-be és csak potyognak ki a végén a
hangszerek igen tehát az az egy teljesen
más akkorárts a javítás a gyártás egy
dolog a javítás meg teljesen más ühüm
egy hangszergyárba dolgozó személy nem
biztos hogy meg tudna javítani egy
hangszert az szalagmunka megszokta azt a
fázist csinálja de a javítás elég
komplex fémmunka famunka
finom mechanika elég komplex dolog ez a
ez a igen most már
most már mindjárt egy órája beszélgetve
erről úgy kezdett összeállni az hogy
ahhoz hogy egy hangszer jól szóljon
először is kell maga a az alapanyag
amiből készítve van az az egy jó
minőségű anyag kell legyen de maga az
összeillesztések fontosak meg meg aztán
ott van a zenész is aki aki még tud
rajta rontani vagy akár javítani a mag
vagy akár javítani tehát egy ez egy
komplexítani mikrovilág úgymond egy
hangszer és egy és a zenészer ajjaj igen
és és tényleg a maga a javításhoz ezt
gyakorlatilag ezt az egész mikrovilágot
kell megismerni amikor jön egy személy
akkor akkor elveszed és persze utána
mondtad hogy mechanikusan javítod ezeket
a dolgokat meg de el tudom képzelni hogy
utána még ilyen finom hangolásokat még a
végén am a zenész kérésére még el persze
sőt én annak örülök ha például jönnek a
klasszikus zenészek megjavítom hangszert
és akkor felhívják a figyelmemet hogy ne
itt még egy picit módosítsál itt egy
kicsit ez ez ez nagyot nyit ez kicsit
nyit mert igazából ebből fejlődsz igen a
zenet történelem során is azért
fejlődtek a hangszerek mert a
zenészeknek és a hangszerészeknek
ötletük volt az újításra és
megvalósították ennyi ezt nagyon jó hogy
felhoztad mert pont a fagottal
kapcsolatban csodálkoztam el hogy
mennyire egy komplex hangszer tehát hogy
kívülről olyan volt mint egy ilyen nem
tudom az erezetét lehetett látni itt
megy egy
fém pantt meg ott megy egy nem tudom nem
is értem egyszerűen nem tudom felfogni
csak csak összességében látom és azt
látom hogy vá ez elképesztő és hogy
lettek ilyen komplexek ezek a a
hangszerek hát ahogy mondtam a
zenetörténelem során folyamatosan
alakultak az úgy kezd úgy szokták
kezdeni a zenetörténelem órát hogy
egy üres csonton átfújt a szél és az
megszólalt igen és az ősember ezt
észrevette utána fúrt rá lyukokat tehát
ez egy legenda de valahogy tényleg így
történt és akkor folyamatosan
kísérleteztek módosították hát igazából
hogyha egy 200 vagy egy 100 évvel
ezelőtti hangzást meghallgatnánk akkor
kicsit lehet hogy elmosolyogtató lenne
ahhoz kép tehát ennyire ahhoz képest hog
most milyen kristály tisztán szólnak a
szimfonikus zenekarok és milyen
tökéletesek a hangszerek
így van és még most is látod hogy
fejlődik tehát hogy így hát a te
életedben a szakmai életedben láttál
most hogy eg új billentyű megjelent vagy
nem t hát igazából én én én azt érzem
hogy már tökéletesítve vannak a
hangszerek tehát nagyon nagyon újat már
ez hülyeség lenne azt mondanám hogy nem
de olyan nagy forradalmi dolgot most már
nem lehet szerintem rajtuk
módosítani ilyen szempontból számomra
nagyon érdekes volt az amikor ilyen nagy
koncerteken láttam például üveghgedűt
vagy nem tudom üvegből volt-e átlátszó
lehet miyakból vagy plexixi és és
számomra tökéletesen szólt az a az a
plexi hegedű viszont hirtelen felmerült
bennem a kérdés oké akkor a stradivarhoz
képest ez milyen lehet ez a ez a modern
anyagból készült modern hegedű és nekem
úgy tűnik minthogyha ezt tényleg tömegre
lehetne gyártani ezt az üveg vagy
bocsánat plexi hegedűt
ez mindenképpen egy m mondhatnánk
fejlődésnek ezt hát inkább
a inkább a lehet csúnya szót mondun
inkább a parasztvakítás része tehát a só
része ez a só része igen tehát azért meg
kell kérdezni egy hegedűst hogy melyiken
hegedűl szívesebben egy szép akusztikust
vagy pedig egy ilyen
elektromos igen tehát mindig az a kérdés
hogy milyen értéket képvisel tudod most
én nagyon gyakran az autókhoz szoktam
hasonlítani a hangszereket
ott is van dciialogám meg ott is van ml
mercedes meg ott is van
rolls-royce nagyjából a hangszereket is
így kell elképzelni jó de az a koncert
amit láttam az tényleg egy nagy só volt
tehát látszodt hogy hogy hogy hogy sok
ember ment el rá és hogy tehát nem nem
az volt hogy egy ilyen olcsó kicsi
műsorka volt hanem tehát hogy látszott
hogy belerakták a pén hát gyanítom
igazából hogy az egy elektromos hegedű
volt ki volt hangosítva igen elektrom
igen igen hát igazából ott már már a
tehát mi a lényege az elektromos és az
akusztikus hegedűnek attól tökéletesek
azok a régi akusztikus hegedük hogy
mennyit kellett gondolkozzon hány év
tapasztalat kellett annak a mesternek
amíg azt a tökéletes formát azt a
tökéletes anyagvastagságot kidolgozta
hogy amikor egy koncerter meghúzza azt a
hangot akkor betöltse a termet nem volt
erősítő nem volt pzzo technológia nem
volt semmi ezért tökéletesek azok a
hangszerek amióta elektromos hangszerek
vannak ugye úgy kell elképzelni mint az
elektromos gitárnál bárezek a húr annak
van egy hangszedője azt kierősítjük és
akkora hangerőt adok neki amekkora kell
a vonó tehát akkor a stradivári
hegedűnek valójában ez a nagy hozzáadott
értéke hogy elkapták ezt a tökéletes
arányt ami betölti a teret h ítás nélkül
és és és és gyönyörű szép hangot és
olyan anyagokat
használtak nem tudjuk hogy mit hát ez ez
a titok igazából hogy mivel pácolták le
azt a fát milyen természetes anyaggal
akkor nem voltak kemikáliák vagyis
voltak de természetes alapú volt
minden és megtudták a tökéletest ugye
ahogy michelangelo is rengeteg sok
gyönyörű szobrot meg meg festményt meg
mindent készített úgy ezek a művészek is
a garnéri a strtradivári ez
világklasszikus mai napig arra a formára
készülnek a
hegedük és akkor nem volt
internet leültek és megcsinálták
hm azt el tudod képzelni hogy egy ilyen
plexi szaxofonon fognak játszani létezik
létezik tudsz rendelni az internetről
magadnak átlátszó szaxofont és és jól
szól
nem nem megszólal szxzofon hangja van de
ilyen temuró rendelt kezdő így van
expressz társai tehát akkor a
professzionális zenészek valójában
vissza kell térjenek örökké a klasszikus
hangszerekhez klasszikus anyagokból
készült nem kell semmit se kell az hogy
vissza kell térjenek ezt azt nem tehát
ahhoz hogy akkor olyan szinten játszanak
plexi szxofonon nem fogak tni hát aki
egy akusztikus hegedőn tökéletesen
játszik annak már a gyerekjáték egy
elektromos hegedő jó kicsit másképp kell
húzni meg másképp reagál mert nem a
hangszertest rezonál a hegedűsök megz
sokták hogy itt itt itt a nyaka mellett
a füle mellett és rezonál az egész
hangszer érzi érzi gyakorlatilag eggyé
tud válni a hangszerrel érzi a
rezonanciáját ott meg a húrezeg a pedzo
felveszi és a hangfalba hallja a hangot
ez a különen teljesen más lehet igen így
van
igen hát elkalandoztunk a fúvós
hangszerektől egy kicsit igen
elkalandoztunk de nagyon érdekelt mert
mert mert igen tehát hogy az egyik ami
ami még nagyon érdekel most azért a
stráivarról beszélgettünk mert
műveletlen vagyok és az volt az egyik
példa amit konkrétan tudok hogy egy
hangszer többet ér mint maga az anyaga
tehát hogy hogy most beszélhetnék elvis
pressleue gitárjáról is de hogy az
említetted azt is hogy vannak olyan
hangszerek amik többet érnek mint maga
az anyag a múltja a és és gondom a
hozzáadott érték gondolom hogy akkor
akkor a fúvós hangszerek területén is
vannak nagyon híres hangszerek amit nem
tudom ki játszott rajta most milyen
híres jazzzenész vagy milyen híres hát
ugye mitől híres a hangszer hogy xy
művész játszott rajta vagy pedig azért
híres hogy tényleg nagyon jó ühüm kettő
közt van különbség tényleg nagyon jó
hangszerekel játszottál te is engedték
hogy kipróbáld tehát olyan ami tényleg
világszínvonalú és össeset kipróbálom
mindig de ezt hogy hogy hogy képzeljem
el most egy híres művisz bejön és tehát
hogy nem feltétlenül úgy értem hogy
hozza hozzád javítani hanem tegyük fel
van le őséged meg felkeresni egy művészt
és megkérni hogy esetleg belefújhatnék-e
a szaxofonodba mitől lesz másabb az is
egy
szaxofon ugye ez a kérdés mitől les má
ugye megboldogult
csepregi gyula
szaxofonművész hangszereit szokták úgy
éltetni és ha valahol árulják akkor ez
csepregi gyuszinak volt a a szaxofonja
tudod mindig ez nézőpont kérdése van aki
ezért bármennyi pénzt képes kifizetni
mert ez a szövé volt igazából az is egy
ugyanolyan hangszer mint a többi két éle
van a dolognak hm kii válogasson
igen tervezeden más hangszerekkel is
foglalkozz a jövőben abszolút nem
a jópap is holtig tanul a hangszerész is
egész életén keresztül tanul lehet hogy
bejön öt év múlva egy olyan javítás hogy
addig nem csináltam olyan az elmúlt
évben emlékszel-e valamire amit tanultál
újat mindig tanulok újat mindig tanulok
újat egy egy olyan egy példát tudsz-e
mondani
igen
például rengeteg kontrafagottot
javítottam mostanában hát azt úgy kell
elképzelni a fagottnak is elég mély
hangja van de egy kontrafagottnak aztán
tényleg ilyen nagy röfögős és körülbelül
mostá javítottam négy három-négy ilyen
hangszert és ott is rájöttem sok-sok
apró dologra tehát azáltal javítod
azáltal fejlődsz te is és hát így van ez
egy olyan szakma
hogy gyakorolva a szakmát tanulod meg
igazából ezt nem lehet könyvekből
meg tehát az elméleti alapjaid úgy látod
hogy most már megvannak kellően az
elméleti alapot azt az ember megtanulja
igazából
hangszerész iskolát is lehet magas
színvonalra emelni martner kirtyenben
németországban létezik ilyen hogy
hangszer mérnöki és akkor ott már
hangszer tervezés van gyakorlatilag meg
meg ilyen dolgok az az meg az az már a
szakmának a csúcsa
gyakorlatilag itt igazából egy-egy
elkészült modell háta mögött például a
yamaháróal beszélgettünk a japán cégnél
mérnökök hada méricskélte évtizedeken
keresztül tervezte kísérletezett azért
hogy egy adott modell például így
szóljon ahogy most szól tehát ebben
hatalmas mérnöki munka van papíron ki
lehet számolni hogy hova kell azt a
hangjukat fúrni hogyha ilyen dőlésű
kónusz van érdekes az már egy az
hangszertervezés az már egy teljesen más
színvonal inkább az már a az informatika
meg a matematika meg a fizika része h
itt hangszerjavításnál anyaggal meg kell
tanulni dolgozni és mindegyik
hangszernek a sajátosságait meg a
különlegességeit meg kell tanulni de
amúgy ez amit mondtál hogy ha ezelőtt
egy 100 évvel játszó zenekarnak a a
hangzását hallgatnánk meg teljesen más
lenne mint most mert most nagyon-nagyon
tökéletes de akkor el tudod képzni hogy
100 év múlva ugyanezt fogják majd
mondani a mostani nem tudom hogy mi lesz
100 év múlva egyáltalán fognak biztos
fognak ezt lehet még fejleszteni ezt a
mostani profizmust amivel játszanak a a
klasszikus zenészek tökéletesen tehát
tökéletesítve van már minden itt a
hangolási problémákkal vannak
folyamatosan ugye
a normál a az 440 hzen van és
folyamatosan nyomják fel tehát ezelőtt
például 100 évvel vagy 150 évvel nem né
40 volt az a hanem csak 438 vagy 435 és
ezért van hogy a mai fülnek itt igazából
kómákról tehát a a félhang félhangnál is
kisebb hang közökről beszélgetünk hogy
így folyamatosan megy fel megy fel a
hangolás ennek mi az oka hangosabbnak
tűnik hogyha picit magasabb hm és
például egy 50 évvel ezelőtt legyártott
klarinét lehet jó szól tökéletes de a a
442-re behangoló sz fonikus zenekarba
már hamis lesz már karmester fogja
inteni hogy ott egy kicsit intonálj
fennébb és nem tudsz fennébb intonálni
mert arra a hosszra van legyártva a
hangszer és ahogy így menjünk vissza az
időbe igazából annál hosszabbak voltak
annál mélyebb volt a a a hangolás így
kell elképzelni tehát egy középkorban
teljesen más másképp szólt a
zene van-e még valami amiről
beszélgetnünk kellene még van egy pár
lezáró kérdésem de valamit hagytam-e ki
amiről érdemes lenne beszélni hát há
hogy fogalmam sincs igazából tehát tudod
hát úgy a személyemet érinti hogy ki
vagyok h honnan jöttem van-e gyerekem
vagy ha szeretnéd ezeket megkérdezheted
abszolút egyik kérdésem az lenne hogy
van-e valamilyen állomprojekted amit még
meg szeretnél így csinálni a következő
20-30 évben ami amit így látsz magad
előtt így
hangszerjavítás van igen a
hangszerkészítés ugye nekünk fúvósoknak
elég
lelombozó nem lelombozó hanem
ellentétben egy hegedűkészítővel a
hegedűkészítő 10 szerszámból alkot
folyamatosan új hangszereket készít
nálunk ahhoz hogy egy fúós hangszert el
tudj készíteni kell egy gyár profi gépek
kellenek profi fémmegmunkálás profi fa
megmunkálás nekem nagy álmom hogy
tárogatókat készítsek majd hogy átózzig
azt a hangszert én gyártsam le ehhez
egy idő kell mert most a javítások úgy
lefoglalnak meg a család meg minden hogy
erre abszolút nincs idő az tényleg a
hangszerkészítés az zabálja az időt a
másik meg a géppark oda olyan olyan
mennyiségű pénzt kell invesztálni hogy
na az az álmom igazából hogy hangszert
készítsek ne csak ne csak
javítsak szeretem azt a részt amikor
például készíteni kell alkatrészeket egy
adott hangszerhez elveszed letöröd bele
törött az egyik része a másikba nagyon
szeretem amikor készíteni kell dolgokat
üm
igazából az a lényege ennek a kézi
munkának hogy valamit alkoss valamit
létrehoz valami maradandót egy
hangszerész mit tud maradandót alkotni
ha készít egy saját
mesterremeket a másik álmom hogy
letegyem a mestervizsgát azt tudni kell
hogy ugye van a
hangszerészképzés és
utána lehet hat évvel aziszem hat év
után lehet mestervizsgát
tenni és most már érik a dolog nem olyan
egyszerű ezt a mestervizsgát letenni ez
miből áll a mestervizsgá hát van egy
bizottság kell készíteni valamilyen
mesterremeket kell írni egy komoly
dolgozatot és részt kell venni a
képzéseken vállalkozásismeret satöbbi
satöbbi szóbeli vizsga meg ez a
mesterremek ez mit jelent hát például
egy y elkészített restaurált hangszer
például hogy megvan az egyik része de
nincs meg a másik része és arról rajz
sincs és te el kell készítsd vagy egy
nagyon régi korhat hangszer ki kell
cseréld az elemeket felkell restaurád
vagy pedig készíts egy új hangszert
igazából amilyen témát választasz és ezt
a szakmai bizottság eldönti
hogy hogy meg mtó métó vagy a mesternek
igen vagy nem nagyon tetszik nagyon
tetszik megadja a méltóságát ennek a
szakmának maximális gondolom nincs túl
sok mester
nincs na hát én én lennék a legbüszkébb
hogyha pár év múlva amikor amikor
odakerülünk akkor tényleg egy mesterré
válhass
addig mit üzensz azoknak akik most
fognának neki ennek a szakmának hát
kitartást és rengeteg sok
türelmet amikor én kimentem budapestre
akkor azt hittem most jön a székely
csávó és megváltja a világot én
megmutatom most a budapestieknek h volt
egy ilyen arrogancia benned valamiér ezt
mi székelyek visszük vissz székely
magyar izé igen és nagyon hamar letörött
a szarvam
odakint amikor rájöttem hogy
igazából nem semmi nem vagyok de hogy
milyen alázat szükséges a
munkához mennyi mindent nem tudunk
mennyi mindent nem tudunk így van és
volt egy olyan pillanat ami mikor még
nagyon az elején voltam hogy igazából
nekem budapest is sok volt meg ez a az
elvárások is sokak azt mondtam
hazamegyek és aztán így ézbe kaptam hogy
te kijöttél ide hogy ezt végigcsinál és
most a legelső adod alkalommal te
feladnád úgyhogy ezt üzenem a a többi
kollégának jövendőbeli kollégának hogy
ne adják fel sokan akik elvégzik a
hangszerészképzést nem tudnak
elhelyezkedni nem találják meg magukat
és teljesen szakmát váltnak a
hangszerész iskolában rengeteg olyan
osztálytársam van aki már teljesen más
más munkakörbe
mozog
hm nem sokan vannak akik saját műhelyt
csinálnak meg saját vállalkozást igen
hát ez ez valami tényleg olyan hogy
szeretned kell gondolom hogy hogy a
hivatástudat a hivatástudat a
családodról mesélsz-e két szót hány
gyermeked van van egy gyönyörű szép
feleségem és
két gyönyörű kisfiút nevelünk a
nagyobbik az nyolc éves és a kicsi az
két és fél éves é teeljetessé köszönjük
szépen ez el tudod-e képzelni ők is a
hangszerkészítés bocsánat a
hangszerjavítás fele kacsingass ha ha
őket ez fogja érdekelni én mindent
megteszek hogy hogy tudásom legjabát
átadjam nekik én nem fogok erőltetni
egyikre se semmit a az biztos hogy hogy
megkívánni egy csillogószemű apától aki
otthon dolgozik ki az a hangszerjavítást
az az nem lesz nehéz hogyha tényleg ezt
azt látom hogy te élvezed ezt a amit
csinálsz szereted ezt a szakmát igen de
vannak nehéz pillanatok és a család az
látja a nehéz pillanatokat is azt is
látja
amikor fáradtan magamból kikellve
hazajövök reggel és nem vagyok kipihenve
ingerült vagyok azt is látják amikor
estében és éjszakába menően dolgozom a
műhelyben és hullafáradtan jövök de hát
ez az élet ez hozzáartozik nem csak
fenékig tj föl hm az biztos hát
a sok sikert kívánok tovább ebbe az
tehát hogy ezen az úton hogy egyrészt a
családoddal tudj annyi időt tölteni mint
amennyit szeretnél és hogy ez a ezt az
egyensúlyt megtaláld a a lakzi zenélés
és a a hangszerjavítás között
mindenesetre nekem egy élmény volt
rengeteg mindent tanultam tőled és
köszönöm szépen hogy köszönöm szépen
hogy itt lehettem köszönöm a meghívást
és beszéljünk még 10 év múlva után már
mester vagy legyen így köszi szépen én
is köszönöm ha tetszett ez a műsor akkor
iratkozz fel kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel
tudsz támogatni minket köszönjük a
vckker kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre